If you’ve traveled to Hong Kong chances
are you’ve stayed or worked here
amongst the skyscrapers of Hong Kong island
But Hong Kong Island running out of room to
expand.
Housing is the least affordable anywhere in
the world.
And you don’t get much for your money.
The average sized flat is smaller than what
you’d get in Manhattan.
And many Hong Kongers live in apartments not
much bigger than a garage.
It’s because of this pressure that the next
time you visit your more likely to stay here
Across Victoria Harbour in Tsim Sha Tsui.
Tsim Sha Tsui is not easy to say and it's often
mispronounced, so it's known to expats as TST
Today the area is a growing metropolis packed
with a huge variety of restaurants,
modern hotels and sleek museums.
So it’s hard to believe that it once looked
like this
During the 1880s it was a watch post for the
British colony and some of the grand old buildings
still remain.
This is The 1881 Heritage building used to
be the headquarters of the Marine Police
Now it’s filled with high end shopping,
a hotel, restaurants and bars
But most people come here  to take photos
Walk down the road a couple blocks and you’ll
come to Hong Kong’s iconic Peninsula Hotel
Built in 1928 it has made appearances in films
like James Bond and The Dark Knight
It’s known for its fleet of Rolls-Royce
Phantoms painted in the hotel’s signature
green.
For which it holds the record for the largest
ever single order.
Running through the center of TST is Nathan
Road. What started as a muddy, country path
built by the British in 1861, is now a
shopper paradise.
Nathan Road is probably best known for its
tailors and the tradition of tempting, or
twisting the arms of tourists walking by.
Hand made suits start at around $300 but for
higher quality threads go to Empire International Taylors
This unassuming store in in fact the base
of a global operation.
This family run business sells suits around
the world - mostly thanks to word of mouth.
Now you’re dressed for dinner head to the
top of the One Peking Road tower, this gem
of a Chinese restaurant is made to look like
a Hutong, or old Chinese alley
Go up two floors and you’ll find Aqua Spirit,
one of Hong Kong’s premier bars.
It has some of the best views of the city
And when you get tired of the hustle and bustle
of Tsim Sha Tsui, walk over to one of Hong Kong's
most famous institutions - the Star
Ferry
Running since 1888, this is the oldest mode
of transportation across the harbour.
And you can hop on for just 30 cents and enjoy
one of the world’s most photographed harbours.